the use of cluster bombs in the ukraine
war has led to hundreds of civilian
casualties that's according to a global
report that's out today cluster
munitions are considered illegal by most
countries
the cluster munition monitor report says
that at least 689 people have been
killed or wounded by cluster bombs in
ukraine almost all of them civilians
the report says that russia has used
cluster bombs extensively investigating
hundreds of such attacks it also says
that ukrainian forces appear to have
used cluster munitions at least three
times
since 2008 an international agreement
banning the use of cluster munitions has
gained 110 signatories including germany
but russia and ukraine as well as the
united states and a number of other
countries have refused to sign i'll
speak to one of the authors of that
report in a moment but first let's have
a closer look at what cluster bombs are
and what they do
cluster munitions from the ground
[Applause]
beyond the explosions
watch and listen carefully to what
happens next
small dangerous objects continue to rain
down
bigger ones too
[Laughter]
they're brutally lethal weapons
from the air this animation from an ngo
working against clustering munitions
offers a look
the bombs released smaller explosive
submunitions in flight the submunitions
are meant to blow up on impact with
enemy soldiers or enemy vehicles
if not the enemy civilians hundreds of
bomblets spread out over the hit zone
and activists say over 90 percent of
cluster bomb deaths are civilians
earlier this month dw looked into an
alleged russian cluster bomb strike at
this children's hospital in ukraine
holding 237
kids the ammunition parts were
everywhere
fortunately there had been an air aid
alarm before the cluster attack so the
children were in the basement if not we
could have had 237 deaths
ngos warned that the tiny bomblets that
don't explode immediately can look like
a plaything to a child
or they might rest like landmines in
urban spaces or farm fields for weeks
months years after the main projectile
has been hauled away
marianne lotto is co-editor of the
cluster of munitions monitor 2022
published today and she joins me now
from geneva uh marianne why would an
army resort to the use of classic bomb
what's the military advantage here
um at the cluster munition coalition we
don't see any military advantage to such
weapons they are indiscriminate which
means that they cannot differentiate
between civilians and military um they
just kill children uh going in a field
they kill
people using their land going to work
going to schools they prevent them to
access
basic services so there is clearly no
military needs and that's why
we have a convention banning those
weapons since 28.
now you say in your report that the the
russian army has been using cluster
munitions extensively in ukraine and
that the ukrainian army also appears to
have used those bombs in three cases why
are you so certain about the russian
russians using these bombs but not the
ukrainians
i mean it takes time to verify
information and there is also the fact
that russia has been using that weapon
extensively hundreds of attacks so we
have lots of evidence then we need to
take time to verify all those evidence
to make sure that what we are reporting
is as accurate as possible um but this
is basically linked to that it means
that russia has been extensively using
that weapon in the conflict in the past
six months whereas ukraine has had
limited use of that weapon
you talked about the
investigating that you that you do is it
easy for you to get access
uh when you investigate those attacks
no it takes time for sure um and i
should mention that at the cluster
munition monitor we are working with
different organizations and human what's
watch it has the lead on such questions
on news and basically we are relying on
different types you know of information
such as direct interviews with witnesses
from cluster munition attacks
videos photos social media has been
extremely used as well in that conflict
we can also use satellite imagery
and other you know
impact in the street of such weapons we
can identify and and see if it is
actually a customization attack or not
um so it takes time uh you need to make
sure that the photos that you are you
know analyzing is is right and it's not
a setup but
you know with time and commitment and
energy you can you can do the work
now can you explain why some countries
like russia and
ukraine but also the us are not
committed to banning the use of cluster
munition
i mean
they consider that those weapons um
are useful but but as i mentioned
earlier uh we believe those weapons are
simply indiscriminate they are banned
and we are working to make sure that you
know as many countries as possible are
joining are joining the convention and
that's why as well but since there's
been this use of cluster munition in in
ukraine uh lots of states have um spoken
out and to said that you know um using
those weapons is illegal and should
never happen anywhere and at any time so
we just have to continue to make sure
that all the states that are remaining
outside of the convention are joining as
soon as possible
marion lodder their co-editor of this
year's report on the use of cluster
munitions thank you very much marian
thank you